So, it's game show week
and we're gonna bring in some game show energy
to a classic game, charades.
And we're gonna play our version of it,
which is called "Show-rades."
(upbeat music)
Okay.
I like it.
Playing with Dakota today, from our VFF's is Marvilla!
Hi!
(audience clapping)
Hi Marvilla!
Hello Drew, how are you?
Oh my goodness, you're so-
Hi Dakota.
Hi Marvilla, how are you?
I'm fine, thank you.
So, Marvilla, you work as a nurse,
how did you start out that way?
I started out wanting to go to nursing school
because my sister became a nurse first
and I always wanted to care for people
and provide the care that they need.
And so, now that I work for VA Hospital
and I'm a veteran, I have the privilege of doing both.
And you've also given back to your community,
will you tell me about that?
Yes, so my husband Anthony Cobin and I own a food truck.
It's M&M Food Truck, it's named after our mother,
Maddie and Mildred and we often take the truck out,
once a month to feed the homeless, to provide meals for them
because when the pandemic started,
they had to go to different shelters and things like that
and then when the pandemic started,
it limited their access of going in,
so we started going to them.
(audience clapping)
That's amazing.
And you do this out of your own pockets, is that correct?
Yes, ma'am. Yes.
You really are an angel.
Well, on a much lighter note, do wanna play some charades?
Yes! Love to!
Okay, well here's how the game works.
We'll have two rounds and in round one,
if you can guess three charades correctly in 60 seconds,
then you'll win $5000.
(gasps) What?
And then that's not all, there's a bonus round,
if you can guess one more clue,
you'll win an additional $15,000,
making your grand total today $20,000.
Oh my goodness, let's play!
(laughing) I love it! That's the spirit!
Okay, I'll announce the category,
Dakota will act out the clue, if you correctly guess,
you'll hear this.
(bell dinging)
And if you get it wrong,
you'll hear this.
(buzzer buzzes)
Okay, ready?
Ready.
Pressure's on.
Okay, here we go, put 60 seconds on the clock
and your first category is, animals, go!
Okay, elephant, elephant!
(bell dings)
Yes!
Okay, yes!
(clapping)
Your next category is sports.
Okay.
Baseball.
(buzzer buzzes)
Uh, tennis!
(bell dings)
Yes, okay. Your next category is food.
Corn on the cob!
(bell dings)
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
Okay, we'll go to the bonus round.
You've got $5000, all right you go three answers correct
in 60 seconds, Dakota will you act out one more?
Yes.
Okay.
If you can guess this clue correctly in 30 seconds
you'll win an additional $15,000
for a grand total of $20,000, are you ready?
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Put 30 seconds on the clock.
The category is, transportation. Go.
Driving a bike?
(buzzer buzzes)
A bus!
(bell dings)
A bus! Yes that's it!
You did it!
(audience clapping)
(women cheering)
$20,000!
Thank you! Oh my goodness!
Aw, congratulations Marvilla.
How are you going to spend it?
Serving the homeless.
(sighing) My gosh.
That's amazing, Marvilla, you're an amazing woman.
Thank you, thanks for having me!
Our pleasure, thank you!
And Dakota Johnson, her new movie "Our Friend"
is in select theaters and on demand right now,
it's beautiful and she's beautiful in it.
(upbeat music)